wondering are your thoughts about taking CMOS gel? Okay, so I'm not a big fan of CMOS
for multiple reasons. I don't know, so remember with supplements there's a lot of
like new things that come on the market and sometimes the producer of that new thing isn't
really looking out for people's best interest. It's just, hey, if we can push this new thing, we can
make money. Yeah, well, the downside of capitalism is that lots of times there's just people
trying to make money on you and without really a concern for whether it's good for you. And I think
I have some videos on different supplements games to look for and to know whether the supplement
you're taking is a good supplement or it's not your wasted your money or you could be even
hurting yourself. So I even had people come to me that are taking a supplement that was
recommended by their carapter, naturopath, or functional medicine doctor. That's like,
that's just garbage. Why would they recommend this? This is like mineral that is
in an elemental mineral, I mean, okay, I'll give you an example of, it doesn't have to do with CMOS,
but like this is really big in the supplement market right now is these liquid minerals. So
liquid elemental minerals are not good products. That's how we're supposed to get our minerals. We
get our minerals through good grass-fed meat or through vegetables. So we eat our vegetables,
let's say, vegetables take an elemental mineral and then it's reformatted by the plant and double
bonded to a libido acid and then we eat that vegetable. That's a mineral that's double bonded to a
libido acid. That's how we eat, that's how we get our minerals. And then that is easy to digest,
easy to absorb and easy to go into a cell and function through that mineral,
supposed to function within the cell. Elemental minerals are difficult to digest. They're hard on
our system. They can be very hard on our gut lining. They're not utilized very well and they're
not absorbed very well. It's just really a poor source of supplement, but it's really pushed hard
because some supplement company came out with this new fancy product. It's easy to take. It's liquid.
It's just not good for you. It's just wrong. So CMOS fits into the category. CMOS has some other
issues with it too. I think I wrote a blog post about that, but I can't remember if that I can look
more of that stuff up.